show opens up as a man named Michael
wakes up in the desert feeling
disoriented and uncertain of his
location suddenly he hears the sound of
a gunshot and barking dogs looking up he
Witnesses a group of armed men chasing
an elderly man determined to help
Michael rushes towards the old man and
Carries him to a nearby cave sadly the
old man has also been shot and with his
last breath he asks Michael to conceal
his body and informs someone named 554
that he managed to escape although
Michael doesn't comprehend the meaning
behind the request he proceeds to bury
the body before embarking on his unknown
Journey after walking for some time
Michael arrives in an unnamed Village
and hails a taxi requesting to be taken
to a train station however the driver
named 147 appears confused and explains
that his services are limited to local
destinations unable to grasp the
situation Michael abruptly exits the
moving cab and enters a crowded
nightclub there he approaches a woman
and seeks her assistance but before they
can engage in further Converse station
the sound of barking dogs startles
Michael prompting him to flee outside he
coincidentally runs into the same cab
and this time Michael instructs driver
147 to take him to 554. surprisingly the
driver understands this and takes him to
a young waitress at the Solar Cafe upon
entering Michael follows the old man's
instructions and informs the waitress
that he has successfully escaped in
response the waitress identifies the old
man as 93 but hesitates to disclose any
additional information as she wishes to
avoid involvement in any potential
trouble suddenly the armed pursuers and
barking dogs reappear prompting Michael
to run upstairs with no other means of
Escape he breaks a window and jumps onto
a ledge at that moment he notices a man
wearing a hat casually tossing an object
in his hand the next second Michael
suddenly loses Consciousness and falls
from the latch after some time he wakes
up in the village hospital and discovers
that the doctor treating him is none
other than the woman he encountered at
the nightclub referred to as Dr 3 1 1-3
curious about his situation Michael
inquires about what's happening and she
advises him to accept the reality around
him before being discharged Michael has
brought to meet the same enigmatic man
wearing a hat his name is too and he
seems to be the one who controls the
village Michael demands that he be taken
to the American console which can
transport him back to New York however
two who addresses Michael as six informs
him that New York doesn't exist
following this Michael is driven to an
apartment labeled number six which Bears
a striking resemblance to his apartment
in New York the next day while wandering
through the streets of the village
Michael notices two prominent Towers in
the distance driven by his determination
to find an escape he purchases a map
from a local shopkeeper steals a cab and
Ventures out into the desert he then
climbs up to the highest point of a rock
formation and searches for an Escape
Route but doesn't find any overwhelmed
by fatigue Michael collapses on the
ground after a while 313 discovers him
in the desert and takes him back to the
village in her the following day Michael
visits the old man 93's apartment in
search of Clues inside he discovers a
drawing depicting Big Ben in London
Michael then seeks an explanation about
the drawing from 554 initially hesitant
554 reveals to him about 93's dreams
regarding another world 93 believed that
they were prisoners being held in the
village furthermore 554 asserts that
there are others who also experience
these dreams and proceeds to share her
own drawing a recurring Vision featuring
The Statue of Liberty this Revelation
ignites hope within Michael and he
assures 554 that they'll work together
to find a way out of the village Michael
has drawings too many drawings of
McDonald's but he keeps them a secret
for now on the following morning Michael
awakens to the sound of the final rights
for 93 hurriedly he steps outside and
informs the mourners that there exists
Another Place Beyond The Village and
that 93 had discovered a way out however
two dismisses his claims and proceeds
with the final ritual after this Michael
heads towards the Solar Cafe in search
of 554 while outside the cafe he notices
an unidentified man listening to news of
a gas explosion shortly after a
devastating explosion rocks the cafe
resulting in numerous deaths frantically
searching for 554 Michael finds her on
the brink of death in her final moments
she instructs him to follow the towers
in the aftermath of this tragedy Michael
regains Consciousness in the desert
where he had been lying unconscious the
sight of a seagull triggers a childhood
memory of a beach trip with his brother
at that moment a man named 16 awakens
him and escorts him back to the Village
they visit too who insists that 16 is
Michael's brother despite Michael's
denial 16 presents a childhood
photograph is evidence of their
connection confused and unable to
comprehend the situation Michael gets
angry and accuses too of trying to
manipulate his mind in the next scene 16
takes Michael to his home where his
children joyfully welcome him they call
Michael Uncle six stealing Drake's
nickname bold 16's wife then prepares
Michael's favorite meal and the family
enjoys an episode of a soap opera called
wonkers set in the village later in a
private conversation 16 manages to
persuade Michael to consider attending
therapy sessions meanwhile too in his
Mansion attending to his bedridden wife
he administers three different colored
tablets to her but the nature of these
medications remains unknown two has a
son named 11 12 who frequently spies on
his father in an attempts to uncover the
purpose behind those medicines elsewhere
Michael attends a therapy session
conducted by a psychiatrist named 70
along with his alter ego Shadow 70.
during the session Michael opens up
about the seagulls he saw in the desert
triggering memories of a childhood beach
trip with his brother however the
therapist fails to grasp the meaning of
Seagulls in the beach realizing that
therapy won't be of any help Michael
abruptly stands up and leaves shortly
after his departure two visits the
therapist to inquire about six's
progress 70 reports that as expected six
shows resistance to therapy and remains
preoccupied with thoughts of Escaping
The Village later that day 16 takes
Michael to work as a sightseeing bus
driver Michael is nervous as he hasn't
driven a bus in his life but his brother
is pretty sure that he can handle it
Michael takes the wheel and provides a
guided tour of the village to the
passengers while 16 offers commentary on
the various sites eventually Michael
drives the bus towards the desert where
they stumble upon an anchor partially
buried in the sand Michael assumes it is
from a ship suggesting the presence of
an ocean nearby however 16 dismisses it
as a desert illusion and leads Michael
to an abandoned train station triggering
memories of their childhood play time
there they refer to the place as the
edge of the world which strikes a chord
with Michael at that moment a passenger
approaches them and shares her
experience of hearing the sound of the
ocean during her initial visit the next
day Michael takes number 313 to the
ruins and expresses A peculiar
connection to the location trusting his
instincts he discovers an old box
containing a childhood note he had
written through one three regards it is
evidence if The Village's reality but
Michael remains skeptical considering
that it might be a trick later that
night he has a vision of his time in New
York City where he encounters a woman
named Lucy in the vision Lucy approaches
him to borrow his phone and as they chat
Michael invites her to his place while
exchanging personal information Michael
reveals that he used to work as an
analyst for a company called sumacor but
resigned after noticing unusual changes
in people here we learned that sumacor
is experimenting with their new creation
a simulation village where people who
are suffering from problems can live a
peaceful and happy life upon hearing
this Lucy discloses that she also works
for Summa core and informs him that the
company still has control over him on
another sunny day in the village the
tour bus makes a stop at two's Mansion
unexpectedly both two and his son board
the boss making an announcement that a
lucky family will be awarded a holiday
trip to escape Resort the winner happens
to be 16. as a result 16 along with his
family including Michael embark on the
journey towards Escape Resort the
following day during the drive Michael's
Gay's fixates on the towers so he steers
the bus in that direction suddenly he
experiences a jarring vision of the
ocean as well as two seated behind on
the boss after a brief moment Michael
snaps back to reality with a confused
mind he apologizes to 16 for the way
he's been acting and reluctantly accepts
him as his brother however upon reaching
Escape Resort 16 reveals that he was
forced into lying and that they're not
Brothers he admits to being unsure of
what two wants from six but it might
relate to the so-called another world
having shared this Revelation 16 becomes
fearful of the consequences but Michael
reassures him that they'll soon find a
means to escape the village after their
trip Michael 16 and the passenger from
earlier venture out in search of the
ocean after walking for some time they
eventually come across its Majestic
presence in a moment of elation 16
rushes into the water Michael tries to
stop him but proves too late as a
glowing Rover attacks causing 16 to
drown this incident triggers a sense of
panic within Michael prompting him to
return to 16's home and deliver the
devastating news of his demise however
to Michael's bewilderment the family
appears unaffected by the tragedy unable
to comprehend the situation Michael
begins to experience a mental breakdown
in the next scene Michael once again
finds himself flying in the desert and
this time he is approached by a guy
named 909 who leads him back to two the
latter introduces 909 as an undercover
agent and proposes that Michael
collaborate with him to spy on other
covert cells within the village this way
Michael can reach other fellow dreamers
those who can still retain memories of
the outside world although skeptical of
it being another trap Michael recognizes
the potential benefits for himself and
agrees to the proposition their first
assignment involves monitoring a
schoolteacher named 1955 who is
suspected of being a dreamer to carry
out their task Michael poses as a
teacher and keep keeps a watchful eye on
the classroom seizing the opportunity he
encourages his students to investigate
and gather information about what's
really happening in the village
eventually Michael Learns that the man
he knows is too is only the latest in a
series of twos and that there is no one
nor has there ever been as the days pass
Michael uncovers the fact that all the
villagers are spying on each other he
even discovers that 909 is monitoring
his activities and Reporting back to two
as a result Michael also begins to
leverage his undercover role in an
unusual way for his own Advantage one
night while spying on 1995 at his
residence the situation takes a
horrifying turn as 1995 notices their
presence and proceeds to harm himself
with a blade witnessing this shocking
act Michael freaks out and promptly
Russia's 1995 to the hospital after some
time 1995 regains Consciousness and
finds Michael by his side our
protagonist inquires about the motive
behind the self-inflicted harm and
whether he fears anyone but 1995 doesn't
reply to anything meanwhile 313 begins
to sketch depictions of the outside
world one day Michael meets up with her
and asks if she possesses any knowledge
regarding the outside world however she
remains reluctant to disclose anything
to him furthermore she realizes that she
should maintain distance from Michael as
she believes that those who become close
to him tend to meet unfortunate Fates
left with no alternative Michael
secretly starts observing and monitoring
her activities to ensure her safety
unfortunately this secrecy is
short-lived as an anonymous individual
sends her photographs of Michael's
spying on her this breaks her heart and
she didn't expect such activity from him
but little does she know that she is one
of the targets whose life is in danger
the scene then cuts to two's Mansion
where he administers his wife with a
different medication surprisingly
Reviving her from her coma the couple
engages in a brief conversation about
the duration of her coma and about their
son not long after two once again
renders his wife unconscious with a
spiked glass of wine later that night
their son 11 12 covertly enters a bar to
Rendezvous with 909 here it's revealed
that 11 12 is in fact homosexual and the
two of them are having a secret affair
unbeknownst to them Michael discreetly
observes their encounter from a distance
the next day two assigns Michael a new
mission to monitor 909 as his recent
Behavior has raised suspicions and casts
him as a potential suspect subsequently
Michael visits 909's place and discovers
that 1112 is present there as well he
confronts them questioning whether they
were the ones who sent the spying
pictures to 313 when the pair hesitates
to answer Michael resorts to Blackmail
forcing them to keep 3-1-3 out of all of
this or else he'll expose their secret
relationship however Michael remains
oblivious to the fact that 313 is
already held captive in a dark tunnel
alongside other dreamers later 11 12 who
fears being exposed brutally kills 909
by stabbing him and not the way he
typically does shortly after learn 313's
abduction Michael swiftly rushes to her
Aid heading towards the tunnel where
people are treated or engulfed by a
radiant Rover within the tunnel he comes
across a young girl named 1100 who
assists him in locating 313 it's then
revealed that 1100 is one of the
students from The Village School who had
been spying on both six and two this is
why she had also been locked up here but
luckily the trio successfully navigates
their way out of the tunnel the scene
then flashes back to the past where
Michael is conversing with Lucy during
their discussion Lucy reveals that the
people Michael observed undergoing
unusual changes are the ones being
transported to the Village world she
further asserts that Michael himself is
on the brink of experiencing the same
fate offended by her words Michael asks
her to leave him alone before departing
Lucy writes her contact number on his
table urging him to reach out if he ever
needs assistance after some
contemplation Michael realizes that Lucy
is the only person who can offer him
help prompting him to make a call
surprisingly her phone rings just
outside his door upon checking he
discovers Lucy lying unconscious on the
floor he then helps her to get up and
takes her back to his room as she
regains Consciousness the two end up
getting sexy time for real back at the
present Michael awakens in his house
only to discover a news announcement
regarding his appointment with the
Modern Love Bureau where he will be
matched with an ideal soulmate
additionally he finds an appointment
card placed outside his door curious
Michael visits the bureau where he is
paired with a blind woman labeled as 415
who exactly resembles Lucy his soulmate
is blind hard not to be offended by that
following this Arrangement the new pair
meet at a restaurant to get to know each
other better Michael knows that she is
Lucy but 415 has no recollection of life
outside the village nevertheless she
appears to enjoy Michael's company in
their first meeting after conversing for
a while Michael invites her to his place
the same way as he had done in the past
at home as they're about to share a kiss
Michael suddenly experiences a vision of
their past intimacy which unsettles him
in response he inadvertently refers to
her as Lucy causing her to get angry and
abruptly leave elsewhere 11 12 steals
three differently colored medications
from his father's safe and brings them
to 313 asking her help in determining
their purpose after conducting an
examination 313 reveals that one of the
pills is a sleeping tablet while the
contents of the other two remain unknown
probably for headaches and also boners
at the driver 147's residence Michael
enjoys a drink with the family shortly
after they discover a deep dark hole in
their Garden uncertain about its nature
147 quickly reports it to the relevant
authorities in the midst of their
concern 147's young daughter Cycles
towards the hole and tragically falls
into it wondering if two can help
Michael rushes to inform him of the
devastating incident however two
dismisses the hole as a mere anomaly due
to weather conditions it becomes evident
that mysterious similar holes have
appeared in other parts of the village
as well as a measure to address this
issue pigs are distributed to Residents
as their breath is believed to stabilize
the atmosphere okay that was that was
the moment I don't know what the hell's
going on in this show but we'll sniffing
pigs what later Michael and 415 are
brought to the clinic where 313 is
instructed to proceed with the process
of genetic manipulation 313 is hesitant
as she has feelings for Michael but she
is forced to comply because two can
punish her for being a dreamer here it
is revealed that new couples are formed
via Gene alteration initially making
them fall for each other the scene then
cuts to a wedding ceremony of Michael
and 415 in an attempt to prevent the
marriage from taking place 313
approaches Michael and kisses him in
front of everyone this act shatters
415's heart leading her to flee from the
wedding venue Michael follows her to
console her and during this it suddenly
Dawns on him that 415 was simply
pretending to be blind no way she heard
the kiss enraged he presses her to
reveal her true identity and the latter
finally confesses that she is Lucy it
turns out that Lucy is aware about the
ongoing connection between the real as
well as the village world she further
reveals that who brought her to the
village for only one Mission she had to
fall in love with Michael and then break
his heart however she now expresses
relief that he has been freed from her
manipulations devastated by this
Revelation Michael leaves the venue and
walks back home along the way he notices
147 standing near the mysterious hole
contemplating jumping into it in search
of his daughter worried Michael
approaches the poor man and urges him to
remain strong for his wife even though
their daughter is no longer with them he
then pulls 147 away from the hall and
offers a comforting hug moments later
Lucy suddenly appears from behind and
plunges into the mysterious hole filled
with grief Michael screams at the gates
of two's residents vowing to seek
revenge for 415's death across the
street another man bearing a striking
resemblance to Michael observes him
close that night 313 awakens from a
nightmare only to find six sitting on
her bed he questions her about why she
kissed him at the church and she
confesses that she couldn't resist the
impulse sixth then proceeds to kiss her
but she is overwhelmed by more Visions
causing her to abruptly stop the very
next day Michael visits 313 at the
clinic and expresses his sorrow over the
loss of 415. this puzzles 313 and she
wonders why he didn't seem concerned
about 415 the previous night confused
Michael denies having been at 313's
place the night before he then
approaches 147 but the latter also walks
away from him stating he doesn't want to
fight him again confused and worried
Michael returns home only to find his
place in disarray these events intensify
his stress as he struggles to comprehend
the unfolding situation later on Michael
attempts to speak with 147 but at the
same time he notices his doppelganger
and gives Chase six successfully
apprehends the duplicate within a
building where they engage in a brawl
here we learn that the duplicate calls
himself off two by six
a vengeful version of six who has a sole
mission of killing two and being named
after a piece of wood despite our
protagonist also disliking too he stops
his double from committing the crime he
says that they will have to act calmly
or else trouble will come meanwhile
there is also a duplicate of two
wandering within the village labeling
himself as the unto or the numberless
who has a different purpose this is
becoming some Kingdom Hearts ass [__]
shortly after 147 finds unto and brings
him to his home to protect him from
detection as a numberless Wanderer
however 147 can't hide him for long as
the dogs looking for the impersonator
arrive and Chase unto away elsewhere 11
12 administers a medication to his
mother and finally awakens her this is
the first time he spends quality time
alone with her during their conversation
11 12 inquires whether he can go to the
other place in response his mother
reveals that it's not possible for the
ones born in the village to leave
although initially saddened by this
revelation 11 12 somehow manages to calm
himself down realizing there is no
solution he then gently puts his mother
back to sleep meanwhile 313 continues to
be plagued by unsettling Visions
overwhelmed she flees her apartment and
eventually finds herself in the heart of
the desert there she discovers a glass
door adorned with the Summa core logo
intrigued she enters and is astounded to
discover that it serves as a portal to
another world in the real world Michael
goes back to the Summa core building and
makes his way to a specific floor upon
entering he gazes through a window and
is stunned to spot six in the village
desperate to grab six's attention he
pounds on the window but his efforts
prove futile it turns out that the Summa
core building is none other than the
tower that is seen from the village just
then an approaching woman informs him
that his car is ready to take him to his
appointment with Mr Curtis the village
is experiencing an expansion as an
increasing number of newcomers arrive
unlike six these newcomers believe they
are coming from the village rather than
from another other worlds meanwhile six
experiences intensifying pain within his
body and discovers that he is slowly
dying he currently finds himself at the
cemetery where he meets 11 12 placing
flowers on the grave of 909 six proposes
that they work together to escape the
village however the young boy expresses
no desire to leave the village in the
real world Michael is escorted to Mr
Curtis's car where we recognize the
driver as 147 from the village upon
arriving at their destination Michael
meets Mr Curtis and his wife Helen who
are none other than two and his wife
from the village it's all coming
together now wait no it's not Mr Curtis
explains that the village is an
experiment taking place within Helen's
mind and that she has sacrificed herself
so that broken people can have better
lives following this he takes Michael
into the city showing him the positive
impact the village has had on people
suffering from various diseases in an
unexpected turn of events 11 12 who
feels like a prisoner within the village
enters his parents bedroom and
suffocates his mother to death before
committing the unthinkable later that
day two returns home and is heartbroken
to discover the lifeless bodies of his
wife and son as a consequence of this
event The Village begins to experience a
surge in mysterious holes that threaten
to engulf its inhabitants the following
day the villagers assemble for the
funeral of eleven twelve six also
attends and miraculously his sickness
has disappeared six implores two to
release the villagers before they fall
victim to the destructive hole staring
The Village apart in response two
unveils a version of the truth
acknowledging that they're all prisoners
he reveals that the only means to close
the holes is for a dreamer to take his
wife's Place hearing this 313 decides to
sacrifice herself to save the other
people she steps forward and takes the
three different colored pills provided
by two in addition to this two delegates
the responsibility of the village to six
appointing him as number one with this
he places a grenade in his mouth holy
[__] and commits
that's one way to do it you savage you
in the real world Mr Curtis introduces
Michael to Sarah who is the real life
counterpart of 313 from the village
Sarah is in a state of near delusion
grappling with the aftermath of
childhood abuse as 313 consumes the
pills in the village Sarah collapses in
the real world prompting Michael to
offer his assistance in the final scene
we see Michael who assumes his position
as the new head of sumacor meanwhile six
into sedated 313 sit together in the
desert of the village six vows to
transform the village into a place of
goodness and promise while 313 sheds a
drop of tear from her eyes
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching